The first step to finding Udacity forums
is to know the right links on the site.
When you first sign in
to your Udacity account,
you're directed to your home page.
Here's where you find your path for
your specific nanodegree program.
Here we're using the Tech Entrepreneur
Nanodegree program as reference, but
all programs will have
a similar home page.
Up at the top,
you'll see a Resources tab.
Among other things, we see that there
is a link to the discussion forums.
This will bring you to
your program's forum.
Another way to access the forums
is through your classroom.
You can be redirected to the forums by
clicking on the chat bubbles to the left
here or underneath the Get Help
on the right hand of the screen where
it says Rejoin the class discussion.
When you are directed to the forums,
there are several categories, and
each has a purpose.
The first category is your program's
broadcast or announcement thread.
Here there will be announcements for
webcasts and other additional resources
that your coach wants you to know about.
The cafe or community category is
a place where students are welcome
to network with classmates,
ask general questions or
have fun conversations
about just about anything.
Then below these two,
you will find specific categories for
each of your program's projects.
Questions related to project content or
questions about project
requirements may be posted here.
Now let's get some practice
posting on the forums.
I'll go ahead and
click into the Community here.
Now, let's say I want to create a whole
new topic to ask my question or
start a new conversation.
To do that,
I can click on the + New Topic button
at the top right corner of the screen.
This will direct me to a screen
where I can start typing.
Be sure to have a useful title for
your post to help others find it.
Let's say I want to post about
favorite places to study.
So, I'll title this Where are your
favorite places to study?
Then, we can go down below and
start entering text.
As you can see,
to the right of the text box, there
is a preview of what you are typing.
This can help you see
what the postal look like
before you hit the Submit button.
When I'm done entering my text I can go
down to the lower left hand corner and
click the Create Topic button, or, if I
decide not to want to post after all,
I can click the Cancel button.
There are three important icons at
the top right hand corner of the forms.
The magnifying glass allows
you to search the forums for
specific content created
by other students.
To the right of the magnifying
glass is the hamburger menu,
which kind of looks like
a stack of pancakes.
Here, we can find links to
specific categories in the forum.
In this menu,
you will also find a link to a page
with frequently asked questions.
Lastly we see my profile image.
Clicking on this will direct me
to my forum account information.
That's a quick introduction to
Udacity's forums, and the where and
how to post a comment.
That's a quick introduction
to Udacity's forums and
instructions on how to post a comment.
Be sure to utilize the forums
throughout your nanodegree journey.
Happy learning.